et sur les chaînes ont après pour la la
formule mathématique en fait donc frères
la sorte alors l'idée de nation
collaboration l'avion approche avec les
élèves année intéressante puisqu'on leur
dit bon voilà on parfois on passe par
les drailles est ce qu'on a le droit
qu'est ce que fait google
devaux de vos coordonnées personnelles
avec
m
[Musique]
on sait faire mais on n'a peut-être pas
toutes les compétences pour le faire au
mieux on va dire on peut là en profond
tant de points de vie avec des prof
d'informatique par exemple on peut
améliorer ce qu'on fait
[Musique]
pour discussion que
folie ca on va dire voilà accès
discussion il l'école se doit d'être
dans son époque
à ce titre-là d'utiliser et de réaliser
les apprentissages haut et par le
numérique au numérique parce qu'on doit
on se doit par exemple d'éduquer les
élèves à la bonne utilisation d'internet
par exemple mais également
profitez des avantages du numérique pour
améliorer les apprentissages
prési